in the midst of a real-life pandemic
some viewers might want some sort of
glimpse into what might be on the
horizon but while there are plenty of
pandemic films out there not all of them
are created equal so here are the best
and worst pandemic movies you can watch
today in the midst of the corona virus
outbreak Steven Soderbergh 2011 film
contagion skyrockets it's at the top of
the rental charts and there wasn't
exactly a surprise as to why Soderbergh
scrim yet gripping portrayal of a
worldwide pandemic seemed to echo
exactly the state of a world adversely
affected by covert 19 and with an
all-star cast contagion pools are
screened by killing off one of its a
listers and the very first scene if
you've somehow avoided spoilers by now
we won't ruin it for you but the scares
and shocks continue at a breakneck speed
until the film's very end when it was
released in 2011 contagion performs well
with critics and at the box office and
scientists even went out of their way to
praised the film's accuracy however
nearly 10 years later the film has seen
a massive resurgence thanks in large
part to his accurate and optimistic
portrayal of the scientific community's
ability to fight infection and disease
no matter how dangerous
none of the Resident Evil film
adaptations are particularly great with
most of them boasting pretty bleak
scores on Rotten Tomatoes but according
to the numbers Resident Evil apocalypse
is the worst of them all with the lowest
rating in the entire series specifically
20 percent this sequel to the 2002
original Resident Evil was released in
2004 and it clearly didn't stand up to
his predecessor apocalypse finds
Resident Evil's protagonist Alice held
captive by the umbrella corporation a
pharmaceutical company investigating the
zombie outbreak that happened during the
first film as Alice and other survivors
try to outrun the zombies which if
overtaking the nearby Raccoon City our
hero discovers some unsettling secrets
about him brothers recent experiments
and exactly how they've created this
quickly growing pandemic according to
Ashford umbrella no they can't contain
the infection so it's sunrise this
morning record city will be completely
sanitized
if you're looking for a pandemic movie
to occupy your time
apocalypse probably isn't it unless
you're looking for a truly terrible
movie to distract you it's low critical
score led to some pretty rough reviews
including one from Roger Ebert where he
called the film a quote utterly
meaningless wait
of time so all in all it might be best
to avoid it even in the event of a real
apocalypse based on a non-fiction book
by Richard Preston called the hot zone
Wolfgang Petersen's 1995 pandemic film
outbreak depicts well the outbreak of a
serious disease similar to Ebola that
begins in Africa and eventually spreads
to the United States when the virus
reaches a fictional small town of Cedar
Rapids both the CDC and the Army's
research wing dedicated to infectious
diseases must fight the pandemic along
with civilians while they all realize
just how serious of a threat they face
despite the film seriously stacked cast
it received mixed reviews upon its
release but in the years since it came
out it's become endlessly rewatchable
especially when people are looking for a
classic pandemic film if you want to
film about surviving the worst possible
virus outbreak is definitely a good
choice for your upcoming Netflix queue
anyone who's currently stuck inside row
in the covert 19 outbreak is definitely
familiar with the concept of cabin fever
but apparently even a real-life
quarantine isn't as bad as a 2016 film
cabin fever a remake of Eli Roth's 2002
film of the same name cabin fever
focuses on a group of young vacationers
who develop a super contagious illness
after running into an infected hermit
near their rental cabin though the
original film garnered positive reviews
a 2016 remake didn't fare quite as well
director Travis sir Rooney tried as hard
as possible to stay faithful to the
original film even going so far as to
use Rus exact script despite the fact
that he cut nearly 1/3 of the plot and
though Roth eventually praised the
Rooneys approach to the material critics
definitely didn't thanks to a slavish
faithfulness lack of reason to even
exist and decidedly d-list cast cabin
fever garnered a rare 0% rating on
Rotten Tomatoes proving that sir Rooney
shouldn't let sleeping dogs lie with
this film when it comes to modern zombie
classics Danny Boyle's 2002 film 28 days
later is definitely the top of the pack
a deadly and devastating virus ravages
London after environmental activists
inadvertently release infected
chimpanzees from a research centre and
into the city and in the aftermath Jim a
bike messenger in a hospital with an
unrelated coma wakes up to find the
normally bustling city deserted and in
ruins with no idea what could have
happened
[Music]
eventually gym meats and teams up with
other survivors as they tried to escape
the outbreak but in the process that
they discover a horrible secret about
the disease itself and about major Henry
West who seems helpful at first but hey
you can't always trust Doctor Who the
film was our success with critics and at
the box office thanks to his political
message and excellent central
performances and a few years later is
spawned a well-regarded sequel twenty
eight weeks later Boyle has dropped
numerous hints at a third film which may
be titled 28 months later could be in
the works someday giving fans some hope
that there's even more to the story
when it comes to zombie films few names
Lumis largest George a Romero the famous
director who's largely credited with
making this genre mainstream thanks of
films like Night of the Living Dead and
the original Dawn of the Dead however
even creative geniuses can have their
misfires as Romero showed with 2009
survival of the Dead officially the
final entry Romero's Night of the Living
Dead series the film follows a group of
National Guard members presumed missing
and briefly glimpse in a previous
installment diary of the dead and their
struggles on the mysterious and fraud
Plum Island ultimately the film garnered
pretty terrible reviews across the board
with critics calling it's entirely
uninspired and lacking in ideas what
makes it even sadder is that it was
Romero's final film before he passed
away in 2017 but survival of the Dead
notwithstanding his legacy remains
intact they're coming to get you Barbara
South Korea's cinematic landscape is
finally gaining international
recognition
thanks to parasites historic victory at
the 2020 Oscars the country's incredible
films are now getting the attention they
deserve but those in the know are
familiar with some of the best South
Korean films around including train to
Busan directed by well-known South
Korean director Yoon sang ho train to
Busan tells the story of a group of
people stuck on a train that suddenly
experiences a zombie outbreak out of
nowhere as the healthy people left on
the train struggled to contain the
disease and escape the zombies their
true natures are revealed as they try to
reach the quarantine zone in Busan and
as the survivors lose family members and
make enormous sacrifices to try to get
to a safe place the outbreak runs
rampant throughout the train splitting
survivors and the different cars as they
do their best to survive thanks to its
incredible action sequences and the fact
of storytelling train to Busan remains a
South Korean favorite with critics and
fans alike in 2020 it was announced that
a sequel bandeau which means peninsula
is on the way once of of that remake is
also coming meaning audiences will be
able to relive train to Busan all over
again before the next part of the story
arrives despite a cast full of
well-known faces and the new original
premise some pandemic movies just full
shorts and a 2009 film couriers as a
perfect example directed by Alex and
David past or the film follows a group
of young adults experiencing a major
pandemic in the United States Brian and
Danny two brothers decide to gather some
friends including Brian's girlfriend
Bobby and Danny's friend Kate and escape
to a secluded beach which they believe
is safe from the virus however on their
journey there they find themselves
facing infection
I said right now unfortunately for
carriers the film susceptor was impeded
by an extremely limited release and
though many critics praised the
performances the film's extraordinarily
dark ending drew criticism if you really
run out of other choices when it comes
to pandemic movies carriers might be an
option but it's definitely not a first
pick the idea of a zombie apocalypse is
definitely terrifying but that doesn't
mean parts of it can't be hilarious
luckily for audiences a Simon Pegg and
Nick Frost explored the funny side of a
frightening pandemic and Shaun of the
Dead their critically beloved 2004
comedy as Shaun and Ed the pagan Frost
tells a story of two relatively
laid-back guys who end up surrounded by
a surprising zombie outbreak and must do
their best to survive or at the very
least make it to the pub for some points
go to the Winchester have a nice pint
wait for all this to blow over with a
plan in place that involves drinking at
the Winchester until conditions are
safer short an ED try to gather their
friends and family to keep them safe and
though it's pretty easy to outrun the
super slow zombies depicted in this
particular outbreak there's still plenty
of stumbling blocks for the gang to
overcome with a supporting cast that
includes names like Bill Nighy and Lucy
Davis as well as a surplus of excellent
jokes and plenty of laughs short of the
daddies of the lights whether or not
there's a real-life pandemic going on
and drawing the 20/20 covert 19 crisis
peg and frost even reprised their roles
for a PSA to reassure anxious fans
during a trying time intended as a
spiritual sequel to a marrows 1978
version of Dawn of the Dead which was
released in Italy as zombie zombie -
directed by Lucio Fulci
definitely didn't live up to Romero's
classic film the film tells a lurid tale
of a small island in the Caribbean
cursed by ancient voodoo which
subsequently spawns zombies as as dead
residents rise from their graves to kill
the living with nasty bites and deadly
infections when a scientist goes missing
while exploring the islands and his boat
returns empty to New York City his
daughter takes it upon herself to try
and figure out what happened to her
father only to discover the horrors
await her on the island there were
performed
would be one of the box office and even
spawned a few sequels zombie too
definitely isn't in the top tier when it
comes to zombie and pandemic movies most
of its poor reviews were due to its
over-the-top graphic nature with true
significant controversy upon the film's
release so if you're looking for
something to pair with dawn at the Dead
it looks like you can skip a zombie - of
course it does have a sequence where a
zombie fights a shark so there's that
though plenty of pandemic movies feature
zombies or deadly viruses some envision
the aftermath and consequences caused by
those types of apocalyptic problems and
twelve Monkeys as a perfect example
directed by Terry Gilliam
the film finds its characters struggling
to contain a virus as force all of
humanity to live in an underground
bunker away from the pandemic after the
virus decimate humanity in 1996
survivors in 2035 use time travel to
discover the origins of the outbreak and
discover the truth about the army of the
12 monkeys a group that may have
released a virus in the first place yeah
I mean 12 monkeys as a result we get a
movie full of goofy characters
timey-wimey twists and some bleak
visions of a very weird future thanks to
Gilliam's sharp direction and excellent
storytelling as well as impeccable
performances across the board twelve
Monkeys were soundly praised and it was
released in 1995 proving to be a success
of the box office as well yes later it
even spawned a spin-off television
series that premiered in 2015 proving
that Gideon's absurd and creepy story
had the potential to live on throughout
different generations after Seth
grahame-smith 2009 novel Pride and
Prejudice and Zombies became a surprise
smash hit a film adaptation seemed
inevitable after years in development
hell that adaptation eventually broke
out and ended up on the big screen
the 2016 film stars Lily James as Lizzie
Bennet and Sam Riley as mr. Darcy
together the unlikely couple along with
their family and friends have to band
together to defeat zombies while still
making arrangements to marry and start
their lives together
maybe the movie should have stayed in
development hell critics bash the film
for not being a particularly fun take on
either Jane Austen's original material
or the zombie spoof genre and clearly
film goers felt the same way the movie
was a commercial bomb earning just
over sixty million dollars on a budget
of twenty-eight million dollars you
might think this film would have asked
in rolling over in a grave but more
likely than us it wouldn't even elicit a
posthumous reaction from the late
British satirist check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]